hello everyone
y'all i'm um
i'm still trying to wrap my head around
that way home
um
i know i was going to get emotional
making this video
um
no spoilers
i promise
i'm going to try to just be real about
this
it's the greatest spider-man movie
to date
hands down
and i think people will say
it is the greatest superhero movie of
all time and i think a lot of people
will say it's one the greatest movie of
all time
um
i i think it was the greatest superhero
movie of all time
and i was not ready
for what
i saw
and that says a lot because if you've
been following me
you know and for those of you aren't
aware i was at the world premiere of
spider-man knowing home um
i was on the red carpet i walked it i
met john watts the director
uh pat and oswald i talked to him i met
seema leo i'm actually really pissed i
took a picture with him then my phone
crashed
so i don't have it i'm actually really
pissed about that see if you're watching
hit me up
but um i won't spoil anything about the
movie but honestly i've been sitting
here since i got at the hotel and since
i took you know the car home sitting in
the uber on the way home since i left
the theater
as i posted my reaction i'm just sitting
here trying to process what i just saw
because from the very start of the movie
it's insanely
awesome
and this is
so oh no i'm thinking of the parts i saw
it's so emotional
it's so emotional in like
like i'm not gonna say it's just it's
insane
i cried
multiple times
like all throughout the movie
i stood up and clapped
at least five times like and the theater
did
like the theater did it wasn't just me
like people were arms in the air from
like the beginning of the movie from
like the beginning of the movie from
parts that we've seen in the trailers
from parts we've seen in the trailers
they don't do justice to what you're
about to see they just don't and i
promise you you don't know what you're
getting into because
whatever my expectations were
i would like instead of like an
expectation it's like oh my expectations
were here and they were here it's more
like my expeditions were here and the
movie was over here
like and and i'm the guy who looks i'm
the guy who knows everything
right
and i'm not saying what i got wrong and
i'm not saying what i got right you'll
see right you can come back to me and we
can talk about it
when people have had a chance to see the
movie and i won't spoil anything in the
days to come either um if i do a video
i'll title it whatever spider-man
knowing home something and in the
beginning i'll say spoiler if you
haven't seen it don't watch this video
i'm not gonna do that to y'all cause
this
this movie was an experience that was
not hyped up as much as it should have
been this
i cannot believe
the depths of this movie i just can't i
cannot believe the depths of this movie
it's insane it's literally insane and
then
and then it just makes you wonder what
marvel has next because this was in like
it was amazing it was amazing
i don't know how to stress that enough i
mean i i'm getting teary-eyed again just
thinking about it because
i it everything that built up to this
was just
it was worth it um
because it wasn't it wasn't the movie i
thought i was gonna see
in such a good way
like
um i'm sad the journey is over but it's
not over because we're gonna talk about
this forever um
as
the actors are incredible
you have you know willem dafoe
alfred molina
marissa tome
john favreau and and tom holland
amazing job sir
amaze i thank you
i thank you for all your work but i
thank you for this film this is very
much
a tom holland spider-man film
it's crazy it's
it's oh it's such an emotional emotional
journey it's just
uh
it's insane like
uh
i'm wrapping my head around it still
like
it's just it's gonna
the ending like just everything is so
crazy and not what you expect and and it
delivers
it just it's just a movie that's a 20
out of 10.
i don't think like i think i think i
just saw it's like out of all the
reviews and rotten tomatoes right now
100 100
percent of all the reviews right now
and like wow
i talked to greg and john from the real
rejects and and
they agree
chris from cosmoculture agrees tessa
from mama's geeky who is a rotten
tomatoes critic she they we all agree i
mean everyone agrees it's
it's literally insane
and like here's the deal so i've been to
red carpets before and i get out of the
red carpets and i'm like wow the red
carpet was amazing and the movie was
amazing but this is like
i care about the red carpet but screw
like
put that aside because this is not me
going oh the whole night was amazing no
the movie
was amazing
i promise you i'm not like mixing up my
feelings for the red carpet that was fun
those once in a lifetime experience
the movie
oh man
i'm just trying to be real you know i
don't have anything prepared but i will
say that
seeing willem the foe
c l from molina their story arcs like
things that i just never thought would
happen
even knowing like thinking that i know
what's going to happen right because i'm
that guy i do the updates you know i dig
into things i talk to people
it's like i i it's like i knew
10 minutes of the two and a half hour
movie
which is baffling to me because i
thought i knew like the whole movie but
no no
and that's what i'm trying to tell you
without any spoilers it's like it's not
what you think it is
like of course some parts are but like
oh you're gonna watch it
and come back to this video please and
comment on this video or find me on
instagram or twitter add me do something
because we need to talk about this i'm
gonna do live streams we'll talk about
this we need to talk about it because
guys
girls ladies gents
this is my favorite superhero movie of
all time
what can't say anything
but it's awesome
and this is
as a kid
who grew up
loving these characters
it's amazing
to see this
really
it really is um
and i hope you all love it
and i think you all will love it
i just i don't know what to say
because i'm not going to spoil anything
about any part of the movie at all
tom hollands and dia jacob benedict
cumberbatch everyone in this movie
congratulations because i i think this
is a
a a movie that comes along
and
these movies don't come along often
like the end games right um
they don't come along often they really
really don't and this was it's gonna
make it's gonna jerk you left and right
and
you're gonna think one thing and it's
going to go the other way and then
you're like oh that's cool then oh my
gosh and
it
it's emotional
it's crazy
and i hope you all love it um
this is my spoiler free review
and um
i don't want to go into too much detail
because i don't want to reveal anything
but i will post
a non-spoiler free review a spoiler
review
um probably thursday when the movie
comes out
um
and i will put spoiler warning in the
title but for those of you who watch it
come by tell me what you thought um and
i'll give you my real true
honest thoughts about the movie i mean
these aren't my true honest thoughts but
i'll go into detail right i love the
movie i can't express so much i love the
movie i can't express how much i think
it's a masterpiece
how it's better than i could have ever
dreamed it could have been in ways that
i never thought of like really
i'm thinking about it again i'm just
getting emotional about it
because
i love this stuff i love you all
this is the
reason why i
i do what i do this movie right here is
why i love
these movies
this is the movie i've been waiting for
that i didn't know i've been waiting for
but it is and i hope it's the same for
you all
so yeah um thank you all
for joining me on this journey it's been
crazy
it's been crazy from
when i was doing theories about in-game
or no i'm sorry theories about infinity
war theories about black panther i think
that was the first when i started i was
doing theories about black panther and
the infinity stones to to now
to knowing people at marvel disney sony
i'm to be invited to these things it's
all because of you and i realized that
and
you know i'm so grateful and i hope you
all know that i hope you all know that
i'm grateful for all of you
and i'm gonna stop talking now because
i'm afraid i'll pull a tom hall and then
spoil something so
i love you all three thousand
can't wait for you to watch the movie
woof